auf dem mond angekommen mit unserer
rakete und das ganze bisher wirklich
einfach nur mit einem command blog
löw ich meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen hier heute am
montagabend zu einer folge der kommerz
und zwar hab ich ja eigentlich gesagt
dass immer am dienstag ein einzelner
command kommt allerdings habe ich mir
gedacht da ja die video days jetzt die
letzten drei vier tage waren
beziehungsweise am wochenende weiter in
berlin hatte ich eigentlich gedacht dass
ich die blogs setzt am ende der woche
hochladen allerdings habe ich mir
gedacht ich hab so bock auf diese blogs
und was ich alles da gefilmt haben
deswegen lade ich dir einfach schon
morgen übermorgen oder nach den parcours
also dienstag mittwoch und donnerstag
kommen die video days verloren dann habe
ich mir gedacht da normalerweise
dienstags immer ein command gezeigte
mache ich das ganze damals heute damit
dienstag mittwoch und donnerstag einfach
durchgängig diese video days or alive
blogs kommen dazwischen eventuell noch
gaming wenn ich schaffe entschuldigung
wenn ich mit ihm fertig aus sie habe ich
habe gerade mathe klausur geschrieben
dass man mir nicht so krass ansieht dass
ich in den letzten nächten eigentlich
nie länger als vier stunden oder so
schlaff hatte deswegen würde ich sagen
fangen einfach auch mal direkt an mit
dem command system comand von minister
gar addons basis der space command der
wie der name schon sagt so ein space
shuttle mehr oder weniger anzufügen der
command ist mega lang ich drücke drauf
fertig danach ihr auf den schalter und
ihr seht schon hier generiert sich das
etwas sehr großes allerdings ist es kein
command wo ich irgendwelche items
bekommen sondern ich muss selber ein
bisschen arbeiten deswegen habe ich den
commander für heute ausgewählt da das ja
wieder so ein bisschen ein längerer
command länger drüber reden kann und
werden die commands folglich ist rein
gepasst hätte und zwar sie wird schon
verdammt verdammt natural disaster ever
the project facto chatamis wissen ich
habe vorhin hier noch andere commands
getestet und jetzt ist und gerade eine
hitzewelle und alles hier unten wird
geradezu verbrennt sich gerade so ein
bisschen das heißt hier habe ich schon
angekündigt welcher command unter
anderem am freitag in der command
folgetagen haben jetzt zwar der natural
disaster spot von minecraft emmerich den
mega cool finde
naja ich hoffe zum zufall dass man immer
noch drin weil ich muss geld dass es
eine reiche welt gemacht jedenfalls ist
diese maschine hier vorne jetzt fertig
und ihr seht schon von mister geräte
wurde hier kein schalter oder schild
angebracht was ich rechts klicken muss
um items zu bekommen sondern ich stehe
jetzt einfach und denken jetzt erst mal
so hin was soll ich tun und das zeige
ich euch jetzt nämlich und zwar nehme
ich eine eichenholz treppe schmeißen sie
noch hin und schweizer darauf ein glas
und ihr seht schon gut
was passiert hier wir haben ein rocket
cockpit bekommen man was los
dann nehmen wir als nächstes jahr den
kohleblock und haben in diesem blog und
schmeißt die auch wieder so zusammen
dann bekommen wir nämlich 1 4 usa und
dann nehmen wir noch eine feuerkugel bzw
feiertage und einen trichter bzw einen
charge seehofer heizt richter genau dann
bekommen wir nämlich einen anderen
trichter und zwar den rocket raster und
jetzt haben wir diese drei teams und
können uns jetzt rein theoretisch noch
in rüstung holen oder ein schwert weil
das wäre sinnvoll wenn wir nach auf dem
mond sind und jetzt nehmen wir auf jeden
fall erstmal rocket cockpit fuel cell
und rocket dressler und schmeißt das
auch wieder alles hier zu dritt zusammen
und wir sehen schon wem ich bekomme ein
rocket ship allerdings wenn ich jetzt
jemand hier draufklicken
diskussionsplattform has not been
constructive correctly die launchpad von
hessen constructed ok heißt es wohl
einfach zwei mal den geschrieben wer
denkt man sich jetzt natürlich erst mal
dass der schädel wie macht man das dann
richtig was soll der scheiß ihr seht
schon laut naviscan schon mal getestet
und zwar sieht es im ganzen nicht
genauso aus wie dort unten das müssen
wir nutzen mich auch wieder selber baut
aber zum glück hat der fleißige luca
hier natürlich schon alles in die kiste
gepackt und zwar genau in die mitte von
diesem sieben mal sieben kästchen ihr
müsst das nicht so mit den blöcken hier
machen können dass auch ein
theoretischer und machen oder auf der
erde oder was weiß ich irgendwo in
jedenfalls bauen wir das erstmal so in
diesem kreis ein
dann nehmen wir dazwischen diese eisen
blöcke die wir da jetzt ja anbringen
davon brauchen nämlich vier stück die
bringen wir hier jeweils an die enden an
dann haben wir hier noch polierten an de
sieht ende seine stände seite auf
englisch packen die hier dran schön hier
vier quadrate damit genau vier mal vier
sind 16 und zwar brauchen wir 16
polnische ende seid dann nehmen wir hier
die netter ziegel treppen und packen an
jede seite hier drei stück davon das
heißt hier drei hin
hier nochmal drei dann kommen hier noch
mal drei hin und auf die letzte auch
noch als letzte seite auch noch mal drei
dann haben nämlich genau zwei stück
verbraucht das war es jetzt an sich erst
mal und zwar nehmen wir jetzt nur noch
das eisengitter stellen davon 1 in die
mitte und dann noch hier drei außen rum
dann nehmen wir noch hier drei hin dann
setzen wir noch eben hier drei hin und
dann kommen hier noch drei hin und das
ist jetzt quasi diese rocket launcher
area die wir jetzt gerade hier errichtet
haben von wo gleich unser rocket ship
starten wir was wir jetzt nämlich machen
ist wir nehmen rocket ship ich weiß gar
nicht warum ich zwar wahrscheinlich weil
ich am grab eines aus versehen
hingesetzt hatte
dann kaputt gegangen ist aber dann
können wir das einfach mal hier drauf
setzen und dann sehen wir schon was
passiert den bruder hockey nice jetzt
hat funktioniert aber noch wir uns
plattform als mobbing das rugby korrekt
wie eigentlich ist das korrekt also
eigentlich habe ich alles korrekt
gesetzt so wie es da und auch gemacht
hat ja genau ich hab alles eigentlich
korrekt hingesetzt die rakete ist auch
da aber die meldung kam trotzdem
irgendwie hat noch ein bisschen zu lange
dauert es ruckelt auch immer so ein
bisschen wenn man zu der maschine
hinschaut wenn man wieder hinschaut dann
läuft eigentlich alles wieder flüssig
jetzt haben wir diese rakete und meine
lieben freunde jetzt der moment auf den
die ganze zeit schon gewartet habe ich
gehe hier einfach mal rein gehen in der
5 modus und es bietet sehr sehr leben
ihr depot so ein bisschen leise das ist
nämlich immer unfassbar wie laut ist da
wirklich packt immer noch zwei
beispielsweise und zwar fliegt jetzt
diese rakete mit und ins weltall wir
können natürlich auch mal ne 5 drücken
dann sind wir auf der anderen seite
nochmals fünf dann sind wir in der
rakete drin
und jetzt meine lieben freunde sind
jetzt auch schon im weltall angekommen
die rakete verschwindet gerade irgendwie
ganz komisch ich weiß nicht warum
allerdings sind wir jetzt im landeanflug
das sieht man daran dass das feuer kommt
das liegt gerade am shader dass es halt
einfach nur blaues normalerweise wäre
dass anwender ohne shader spielt rot
oder so jetzt sehen wir dass nämlich
ganz genau jetzt sind wir hier nämlich
gechillt im landeanflug ihr seht schon
hier die jetzt sind auch ein paar rote
flammen mit drin einfach und jetzt
landet die rakete ganz langsam und zwar
sind wir jeden gottverdammten moment auf
dem mond angekommen mit unserer rakete
und das ganze bisher wirklich einfach
nur mit einem command blog bin ich auf
den mond bin seht ihr schon ich habe
langsamkeit abbau lähmung sprungkraft
und resistenz das heißt ich kann hier so
rumlaufen wie der astronaut hüpft ein
bisschen wenn aber ein bisschen langsam
wenn ich so laufe das seht ihr so laufe
ich ganz normal und das ist halt schon
so ein bisschen langsam
jetzt fragt ihr euch mit sicherheit
mühle ist es eine neue welt oder so
jetzt ihr seht da unten deswegen extra
flachland gewählt haben das immer ganz
gesehen da unten ist hat und immer noch
unsere welt da hat mir das gerade
gespannt wohin hatten wir das glaub ich
sogar woanders gespannt da hatte ich
nämlich diese eisen
block fläche da gewinnen oder alles da
ist die eisen blog fläche da unten seht
ihr das ganze da ist die maschine die
eisen blog fläche wo wir das alles
aufgebaut hatten und jetzt endlich hier
auf dem mond quasi angekommen das ist
eine automatisch generierte landschaft
war sie einfach und hier spawnen wir
schon seht auch mops das ist ganz
einfach so weit seid wirklich einfach so
wie auf der normalen welt ist es ist
halt einfach eine fläche die nicht
ausgeleuchtet ist wenn ich das natürlich
aus leuchten würde alles mit fackeln
würden hier keine mops transport und die
attacke mich dann natürlich auch ganz
klar ich bin hier das gab natürlich im
game 1 allerdings auch ganz cooles und
zwar wenn ich jetzt hier einfach mal
diesen mond theoretisch verlassen würde
ich nehme abschied vom mond
ich bringe hier runter und ihr seht
schon da oben ist die plattform und
jetzt ist es wieder hell und jetzt seht
ihr nämlich da oben was passiert wenn
ich wieder unten bin von dieser
plattform und zwar ist es gleich alles
was wohin der probeaufnahme geklappt hat
klappt jetzt irgendwie nicht weil
normalerweise wenn ich jetzt hier mit
dem spaceship da oben hin fliegen würde
aber das war ein bisschen komisch weil
er reinkam der lounge plattform steam
car repair eigentlich verschwindet
dieser mond wenn ihr davon runter
springt das heißt cool das licht ist
megageil irgendwie für die face com
eigentlich müsste diese mond plattform
jetzt verschwinden und zwar genau wenn
ihr da runter springt und sterbt oder
irgendwie sowas also ich bin natürlich
jetzt nicht gestorben vielleicht lag's
daran aber ach guck mal die verschwindet
auch das war nun grafikfehler auch die
crazy jakub maly verschwindet sogar
gerade ich kann er sogar durch fliegen
ja okay dann sag' das nur von unten so
auswegen im keller oder irgendeine
minecraft grafikfehler das hat man ja
manchmal das war eigentlich auch schon
der komplette command also er ist jetzt
natürlich sieben minuten gedauert bis
das ganze vorgestellt hatte aber es ist
halt einfach so ein bisschen man muss
selber was machen also wenn ihr testen
wollt schreibt euch am besten auf
welcher seite sich zusammen geschmissen
habe oder so da kriegt man da nicht die
items direkt sondern muss sich das
selber so ein bisschen zusammen kräften
das war der heutige command im heutigen
video vom minister gartow ihr findet
seinen kanal in der beschreibung findet
in command in der beschreibung ihr
findet seinen kanal namen in der
beschreibung
ihr findet meine sozialen netzwerk in
der beschreibung ist mein equipment in
der beschreibung befindet weitere ich
möchte es gar nicht so lange halten ich
möchte einfach sagen wenn euch das video
gefallen hat mein schnitt der sich der
außenseiter was auch immer würde ich
mich über eine bewertung freuen
an alle die mich beim trainer oder so
gefragt hatten matte lief eigentlich
ganz okay ich denke das wird mit zwei
sein oder irgendwie so als ich bin auf
jeden fall nicht durchgefallen
und dann sehen wir uns morgen übermorgen
und am donnerstag bei dem video des
blogs wo ich mir jetzt richtig kühl mit
geben werde ich werde zwar donnerstag
eine klausur schreiben aber ich habe
richtig bock die sachen richtig geil zu
schneiden und dann sehen wir uns wann
anders wieder und das letzte wort hat
heute dieses schaf